the nfl draft was last week neat
yeah no i'm a pretty big football fan so
i watched the draft
cool yeah uh yeah it was pretty cool
my uh my favorite team the one i root
for the new england patriots got a good
quarterback so i'm pretty excited
rad that's all you're going to say
just one word exclamations yes
oh i get it you really don't care about
sports at all do you
nope then you know what time it is huh
sure that's right it's time for andy
richter's
sports blast andy richter's sports blast
welcome to andy richter sports blast i'm
andy richter and i'm here to blast some
sports sports me
ow let's start with a sports score
24 to 14. sounds like a baseball score
to me
who knows that means it's time to recap
the nfl draft
nfl draft recap here's who got drafted
johnny tackles sports bulge huge man
sports huge bulge man sports arm smith
sport heath manifold sports runwell
raymond raymond james james sports
alyssa
sport jimmy first down sports he's great
let's look at some of timmy's tape
and more names building johnson sports
farmham fists portray trey draymond
sports the rest were all named steve
uh oh that means it's time for 10
seconds of sports yells
10 seconds of sports yells are you ready
to yell conan
i sure am great tonight's topic
are defensive chefs ruining baseball and
[Applause]
well that settles that tonight's episode
of sportsblast
is brought to you by mind bulge mindful
the best way to out brain the
competition is to bulge your mind
is that a bulge in your mind or are you
just happy to see me
mind bulge my bulge do not ingest
let's go back to sports blast
correspondent conan o'brien
with the top baseball players of the
year so far conan top
mlb calls of 2021. thank you andy
ground out to third base sport home run
to left field
call strike three oh he hit him right in
the middle of the back
wow he's pissed sports he's charged the
mound now the pitcher hasn't been a
headlock
he's wailing away on his head here come
all the other players
holding each other back and yelling no
one's actually fighting
it looks like they're pretending like
they want to fight but they don't really
want to fight sports just a lot of alpha
male posturings
toxic masculinity it's best sports back
to you andy
groovy back to you conan thanks handy
back to you well that's all the time we
have tune in never again
for andy richter's sports blast hit me
i watch the glasses
stop it no no
no no no no
that's a fan for god's sake sorry jordan
klinger
andy richter's sports blast
[Music]
you